Patterson's pass intercepted but he keeps the
pucking at the left Point here's Hughes Alias
Pon Brock besser shoots he [Applause] scores
deser dumps one ahead hoping Miller can get
there first he does he scores what a play by
Brock B to angle that one off the cornerboards
Quinn Hughes back to laery into the middle
Philip heroni still looking for his first goal
as a Hughes moves the Middle with a wrist shot
scores off the glove of K into the net lots of
movement on the Canuck Power Play here's Miller
down to kzco looking across centers and bed in
by besser right at of midair and that'll do it
for period number one Canucks going three for
three on the power play exiting the period
with 84 nothing here's Pon at the offensive
Blue Line cuts across feed Susi nice pass mam
scores Carson Susi put it on the tape here's p
nice pass kusco is in on the right wing Andre
kusco scores there's the sixth Vancouver goal
here's laferty on the right wing Sam lafy round
the net try to ref backed it in it went in off
Ferraro skate and it stays 7 nothing Vancouver as
Suter knocks his man down here comes Hughes three
on one Quinn Hughes Suter scores one last shot
but he tried to pass for Cole and time runs out
on period number two Canucks with four goals
in each of the first two periods and Patrick
enco stopped all 14 shots he seen heroni back for
Susi nice diagonal pass and a one-time in there's
the first of the year Anthony M in career game
number 500 ril Garland with room Conor Garland
shoots and that one off the goal CH and over
top of the net now Garin brings the puck in
front again bili scores he's got two and it's
a 500th game to remember as Anthony M puts the
Canucks into double digits in San Jose he'll
send it in deep and that should do it for this
game the Canucks win in a ROM in San Jose two
goals from Brock besser two goals from Anthony
bili in his 500th game and Thatcher dco gives
up a late one but he stops 29 of 30 and the
kuuu had an 8 to1 win on opening night win this
one 10 to one over the San Jose Sharks who are
now 09 And1 to start the season Canucks improve
to 72 and one as the beat goes on for Vancouver